الرئيس البيلاروسي دعني اتحدث معه يا
بوتين للمره الاخيره نعم ها هو يغادر الى
بيلاروسيا تعود الى اوكارها في صفقه
النجاه لتخرج مجموعه باجنر رابحه من هذه
الصفقه من شركه فاجنر الخاصه الذين اتخذوا
القرار الصائب للتوقف والعوده ادرجهم
وتفادي حمام دم فما كان يعده بوتين
للمجموعه لا يسر عدوا ولا صديق ما بين
عشيه وضحاها اصبحت اعين العالم ترمق داخل
الروسي وتراقبه عن كثب هيبه الدب الروسي
صارت على المحاك حليف بوتين القوي ويده
الحديديه الضاربه اصبح عدوا منافسا ولكن
لا تنسوا ان المنافس الاخر هو بوتين الذي
كان رجل الظل الاول في الاستخبارات
الروسيه ولقب بصائد الجواسي لقد لعب
باعصاب قائد فاقمر واخدقه بالسلاحه ليضعه
امام اختبار صعب ولتصيبه نوبه من جنون
العظمه لكن اهلا ماذا لو نجح الانقلاب على
الرئيس الروسي اين ستكون الولايات المتحده
والنيتو من هذا الانقلاب هل سيتدخلون كما
فعلوا في العراق وماذا عن جاري السوء
لروسيا ونقصد بولندا فهي لن تترك الاراضي
الروسيه دون ان تاخذ نصيب الاسد وهل ستترك
اوكرانيا اراضيها التي التهمها على راسها
جزيره القرم ومن نصيب من ستكون الاسلحه
النوويه وماذا عن حلفاء بوتين الصين
والسعوديه والجزائر وايران وكوريا
الشماليه والدول البريكس وبكل اختصار ما
الذي سيحدث لثاني اقوى جيش في العالم وما
الذي سيحدث للعالم حينها اليكم اقرب
سيناريو
انقلاب خاطب مقاتلون محترفون لا يرتدون اي
شارات عسكريه باقنعه سوداء تخفي ملامحهم
القاسيه وملابسا نظاميه مموات وشبه عسكريه
مجموعه الروسيه التي دعا صيتها في
اوكرانيا وسوريا بجانب مناطق اخرى في
العالم ينشط فيها الدب الروسي مثل ليبيا
والسودان وافريقيا الوسطى ومالي والساحل
الافريقي تاتي هذه المجموعه خلف هذا
العجوز للاثنين عاما بصوته الاجش وبنيته
الجسديه الضخمه وصنعه تزيد وجه المتجهم
انه يفقين بريكوجين الملقب بطباخ بوتين
والذي كون جيشا خاصا يضم الالاف من
العسكريين المتقاعدين والسجناء السابقين
الذين تم تجنيدهم من السجون الروسيه
واستطاع مؤخرا ان يحق اكبر انتصار لروسيا
انتصار لم يستطع الجيش الروسي تحقيقه حتى
تدخل الطباخ وانهى الامر باستيلائه على
مدينه بخمه الاوكرانيه الشهر الماضي والى
هنا فكل شيء يمضي كالساعه ولا تراجع الى
الوراء اكمل السيطره على ضخم وسلمها
للقوات الروسيه وكانه يقول لقد اتممت
مهمتي لا يوجد لدي سلاح اعطوني سلاحا اذا
كنتم تريدون الانتصار لتفتح موسكو مخازنها
وهنا فتحت شهيه طباخ بوتين ليطلب المزيد
والمزيد وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قالت كافه
ما معك يكفي جيشا باكمله قوات فاغنر تسطو
على مخازن الاسلحه الغربيه في اوكرانيا
وجميعنا يعلم كميه الاسلحه التي وصلت من
الغرب لاوكرانيا
يطمع بالمزيد محذرا وزاره الدفاع ان لم
يوفروا له ما يريد سينسحب وذلك عبر فيديو
مصور نشره وشاهده الجميع ليكرر بوتين امره
اعطوه المزيد ومن ضمن ما حصل عليه
والكثير من الاليات العسكريه والدبابات
لتنتابه حينها هفوه من جنون العظمه وينهل
بسيل من الشتائم على القيادات الروسيه وفي
فيديو مصور لقصف في غابه ولا يظهر اي
ضحايا او جثث يصرخ قصفني الجيش الروسي
وليس لديه سوى هذا الدليل ليستند عليه
وفجاه قرر بريغوجين خوض غمار معركه قد
تؤدي به ومجموعته الى النهايه ليدخل في
اول تمرد مسلح في الاراضي الروسيه منذ
الحروب الشيشانيه قبل عقود وذلك بعد اشهر
من صر
الذين اتهمهم بعدم الكفاءه وحجب الذخيره
عن مقاتله غير ان المواجهه الاخيره ذات
التفاصيل الغريبه والمبهمه شكلت مفاجاه
للجميع اذا اردت ان تعرف ما الذي في احشاء
صديقك او حليفك لابد من ان تضع اصبعك في
حلقه ليستفرغ ما في بطنه عندها ستعرف ان
كان صديقا او عدوا ولا بوتين يخرج بخطاب
لاذع ليثير جنون معلنا تخليه عنه هنا وضع
بوتين اصبعه في حنجره ليخرج غضبه وجنون
عظمته ليطالب برئيس جديد لروسيا وذلك في
تغريده قام بحذفها بعد نشرها ويعلن زحفه
المسلحه نحو موسكو
صفقه الكرملين مع فاغنر دارت الاحداث وفي
حين غفله يتدخل رئيس روسيا الكسندر
لوكاشينكو الحليف الاقرب لبوتين والصديق
المقربوجن ليقولها دعني احاول معه مره
اخيره والذي بدوره قدم صفقه
تعتبر طوق نجاه فقد تضمنت عوده مقاتل
باجنر الذين اقتربوا من موسكو الى
معسكراتهم مقابل اغلاق القضيه الجنائيه
والمساءله القانونيه بحق بريكوجين
ومغادرته الى بيلاروسيا ولا يخضع اي من
مقاتل باجنر الذين شاركوا في الهجوم
الاخير ضد روسيا لاي ملاحقه قضائيه بعد
تسريحهم اما المقاتلون الذين لم يشاركوا
فيتم الزامهم بتوقيع عقود مع وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه لنقولها ماذا كان سيحدث اذا تم
رفض هذه الصفقه ماذا تتوقعون من قائد ثاني
اكبر جيش في العالم الذي يمتلك اكثر من
اربعه الاف طائره وقاذفه نوويه
اكثر من 12000 دبابه ونحو مليون ونصف
المليون جندي هل سيعجز عن صد خمسه وعشرين
الف مرتزق من باجنر وبحسب التسريبات التي
نشرتها الصحف الغربيه وعلى راسها واشنطن
والتي تشير الى ان بوتين قد اعطى امرا
عسكريا بتحريك اسطول مهول من الطائرات
وعلى راسها مقاتلات سو سبعه وخمسين 22
والتي تستطيع اسقاط اكثر من اربعين طنا من
المتفجرات وما يؤكد خطه الاباده التي كان
يخطط لها بوتين هو ارساله لكتيبه احمد
الشيشاني والمكونه من عشره الاف مقاتل الى
اطرف موسكو لتعمل بدورها على تصفيه ما
تبقى من مقاتل باجنر بعد القصف وهذا
السيناريو المرعب الذي جعل قائد فاجنر
يمسك بطوق النجاه ويوافق على الصفقه التي
قدمها اللو كاشينكو ويتحرك فورا الى
بيلاروسيا واليكم المصدر جاء التحول وفقا
للكريم بمبادره من الرئيس البيلاروسي
الكسندر لوكاشنكا بعد مفاوضات دامت على
مدار اليوم مع مالك شركه فارنا
وبالتنسيق مع الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين
ماذا لو نجح الانقلاب
دعونا نداعب ذاكره قليلا لقد تسالنا في
بدايه الفيديو عن ماذا سيحدث لو نجح
الانقلاب على بوتين وما الذي سيحدث لثاني
اقوى جيش في العالم بل ان الجيش الروسي
يتناوب قمه جيوش العالم مع الجيش الامريكي
فتره بفتره لنضعكم امام اقرب سيناريو قد
يحدث في حاله اذا ما نجح الانقلاب وهذا ما
يخشاه الكثير من اصدقاء بوتين ويطمع به
اعدائه من جهه اخرى هنا نتناول معكم ما
تداوله العديد من الخبراء الدوليين
والعسكريين في سيناريو رسموه في مخيلاتهم
ونضع تحت كلمه مخيلاتهم الف خط عند نجاح
الانقلاب ستعم الفوضى في روسيا امريكا
والغرب سيفتتحون مزادا علنيا لشراء ولاءات
القيادات الروسيه وعلى راسهم قائد فاجنر
الذي سيشق لهم طريقا كما شق العرب طريقا
امريكا الاحتلال العراق وكل ذلك تحت اسم
حمايه الشعب الروسي وكما يقول المثل
اليمني لا طاح الجمل كثره السكاكين هناك
سيتدخل النيت وامريكا ليبدا بتقاسم حصص
الاسلحه النوويه وابار النفط والغاز
ومناجم الماس والذهب الروسي ليصل لعاب
الدول المجاوره وتصبح غزوه مفتوحه ولن
تترك بولندا الاراضي الروسيه دون ان تقتص
حصه الاسد التي ستعمل على استفتاء للاراضي
المحاذيه لها وتضمها اليها كما فعل بوتين
بالمقاطعات الاوكرانيه الاربعه وسيضمن
نجاح التصويت مباركه الولايات المتحده
ودول الغرب وعلى بكر اوكرانيا فستستعد
بدورها مقاطعتها الاربع واضف على ذلك شبه
جزيره القرم وقد لا تكتفي بذلك لتضم اراضي
روسيه مبرره ذلك بانه تعويض لا عن الخراب
والدمار الذي اصابها من العمليات العسكريه
الروسيه وماذا عن الحلفاء يا اصدقاء ها
نحن في الطريق اليهم في قوانين الحروب
لابد ان تولد من خاصره كل غزو لاي دوله
مقاومه فاذا لم يتم اعتقال بوتين او قتله
في الانقلاب فقد يتراس المقاومه الصديق
الاقرب
ومن خلفه رئيس بيلاروسيا ورمضان قدروف ولا
ننسى شوكه الاسلحه النوويه التي وضعها
بوتين في بيلاروسيا حيث سيستخدمونها
كراكيزه اساسيه لردع الغرب واما الحلفاء
فسيمدون هذه القوه بالدعم العسكري والمادي
كما فعل الغرب مع اوكرانيا انقلاب خاطف لم
يكد يبدا حتى انتهى لنوجه هنا السؤال
اليكم ونطلب اجاباتكم ماذا لو نجح
الانقلاب حقا
[موسيقى]